it's great to be here today
and this is of course a great idea
to organize this with the motion picture
association
and by the way they told me not to say
motion picture association of america
because now the motion picture
association
is controlling the whole world
including china and russia
anyway the bottom line is
also nato is part of this and organizing
this because we want to bring
the big screen back that's what this is
all about
now let me just tell you how i got here
today
rolando who is of course the chairman
of nato he and i we have a good
relationship we call each other every so
often
and then he called me one time or
frantic this was after the january sixth
episode and uh disaster in washington
and he called me and he said this is
really terrible our whole democracy is
at stake here and this is in danger
arnold you still believe in free speech
right
i said yes i believe in free speech he
says good you're going to give one
a may 19th in century city
so this is how i got involved in this
but now
in all seriousness very funny huh i like
that i'm going to talk to you later
but anyway i love being here
and the reason why i love being here is
because i wouldn't be here
if it wouldn't be for the theaters if it
wouldn't be
for the big screen and i always said to
people
you can call me anything you want
you can call me schnitzel arnie
schwartzie
whatever you want but don't ever call me
a
self-made man and the reason why i'm
saying that is because
as i said i wouldn't be here if it
wouldn't be for the theaters
i'm not a self-made man and i always say
this when we have a wrap
party after the movie i say we get the
spotlight
as entertainers and as leading men or
women or whatever
and there is 500
people that are working behind the scene
there will be no star if he wouldn't
have a directive he would never produce
if he wouldn't have the riders
if he wouldn't have the fiancees
if we wouldn't have the camera people
the focus puller
the cable pullers the electricians the
set designers the stunt coordinators
and the list goes on and on and on think
about it i mean how would i
i'm not doing my makeup myself i'm not
doing that here myself
i'm not doing any of this they are doing
it
there so there's hundreds and hundreds
of people in every movie set
that are responsible to make a movie
exist and to make it work and then when
you have the movie done
and you finish you have the wrap party
then starts the post-production
now the work begins again people are
doing the editing
the sound the music special effects
visual effects and all of this stuff
and then you have the movie finished
and now you test the movie and now you
have let's say a straight pen
get a huge score fantastic give a
successful movie but then what do you do
then you need the big screen
you need the big screen because if you
have a movie and you don't have the
theaters you have nothing
yes we have seen over this last year
the pandemic year the people watched
movies
on a little iphone
and the ipad and they have to put their
classes on to see what's going on there
and they're missing the special effects
and visual effects and all the great
stuff that you usually see in a big
screen
but that's what they had to do but
now is the time to go
and wind down this pandemic period
now it's time to get back to the big
screen
i love the big screen and i love the
theater owners and the theaters
i mean think about it that america we
have
5 800 five thousand eight hundred
theaters we have over forty thousand
screens
there's a hundred and fifty three
thousand people working in those
theaters
in the united states
look how many job it creates
153 thousands you see
when you go into a theater
someone has to go and unlock that
theater
open it up someone has to turn on the
lights
someone has to go and project the movie
someone has to sell the tickets someone
has to sell you the drinks
and the food that makes you really fat
so you have to go to the gym afterwards
which
the gym business benefits too